and you think talk about the fishing
zero knowledge proof strongly attracted
hello everyone I'm Yukon John I just
started the assistant professor at Texas
A&M University and today I will talk
about some of our recent work on
constructing efficient zero knowledge
proof from interactive tools and in
particular I'm throwing to the table
efficient interactive proves the chicken
our protocol the concept of zero
knowledge proof has already been
mentioned in many of the previous talks
so very quickly it allows a approver to
convince the verifier that like a
computation for example model as a
circuit on public input X and the secret
witness W and the output is y together
with the proof and then we have
completeness song as and zero knowledge
defined like in this way everybody's
clear with the definition
in general true we are interested in the
following efficiency measures right you
have a pure time proof size and
verification time and for those are
constructions where the proof size is
smaller than the computation or a
circuit we call it assessing zero
knowledge proof and here we also allow
the verifier to interact with the prover
which is not like illustrated on this
light and actually our constructions are
interactive and we can make a
non-interactive easing Flammarion
Renmark remodel so since this was
introduced in the early days there are
so many fancy constructions of journal
proofs and actually I'll give a very
good survey about it and since he's not
here today I'm just going to steal his
slides to make sure I don't need to miss
anyone's work and see those fancy
constructions and here's their oh yeah I
don't have my slices here's the
reference I'm going back to my own slide
so I guess the most widely deployed ones
in practice now is like based on snarks
from early constructions over across a
limit to the like qap based ones
introduced in GPR later there's a
penalty implantation there's a whole
series of improvements on the
functionality its efficiencies and so on
so forth and recently have sonic making
updatable and universal common like
structure reference string and one of
the reason it is like the most widely
deployed one is so it generates a
constant size proof and in practice only
like hundred bytes and the verification
is super fast so this is great for
applications like blockchain but there
are two piece of them advantages of
Snorks the first one is a trusty setup
it requires a structured
reference tree with the trapdoor and you
can now leave the trapdoor and otherwise
there's no security guarantee
and the second one is the poor time is
relatively slow because it requires a
public key operations in particular
multi scaler exponentiation which is the
size linear to the side of the circuit
to address these issues more recently
there are many constructions and
efficient implementing systems and
here's a short list categorized by their
underline technique okay and again this
is just a small subset and I'm mainly
referring to those with implementations
recently and there are many work before
these things - like on the foundation of
these techniques and also recently
there's the lattice based assessing zero
knowledge proof which was presented
yesterday my research is mainly focusing
on this line of work constructing
efficient journals proofs on the so
called the interactive proof and so
today I'm going to present some of our
recent progress along this line and just
to like if some features ahead of time
so systems building on interactive herbs
usually have a fast prover time because
for the main body of the protocol on a
circuit we only require like module
additions and modifications and there's
no expensive public key operations like
a exponentiation parry and then the
birth kitchen time can also be made
succinct if your circuit has structure
in it so this was inherited from the
original paper so when your circuit is
locked spaced uniform we can actually
validate the computation faster than
then then running it locally
and as I said for interactive proves I'm
particularly referring to the double
efficient interact roof
proposed by co-author kalaiy and Rathbun
in 2008 and we will refer refer to it as
the g'kar protocol so g'kar protocol is
a protocol for delegation of computation
so let's say the word fire wants to
evaluate a function mode the circuit on
input acts but he is not like she's not
powerful enough to evaluate on her own
then she can actually use this protocol
to delegate the computation to the poor
side and valid the results by
interacting the prover and the
verification time is actually faster
than computing locally if the circuit
has structure so this is the tikka
protocol for delegation of computation
and actually I'm going to present great
details of Chikara protocol just in the
next several slides so in this talk I'm
going to talk about three improvements
in two of our recent papers so the first
one is to reduce the prover time in gkr
to linear for arbitrary circuits which
is the optimal the second one is to
achieve zero knowledge I turn it into an
argument system and SHIVs your knowledge
efficiently and the last one is a
construction for transparent polynomial
commitment meaning that there's no it's
not based on bilinear pairing there's no
trust setup in this polynomial
commitment scheme and the first two are
in this paper we published in crypto
this year called Libre and the third one
is a follow-up work in summation and the
system is called Virgo because parinita
namely birds taken by Facebook and these
are joint work with the king champion
Bob with Santa
so to start I'm going to talk some more
details about the construction of g'kar
protocol and to start with I would
present part of this sound check
protocol and I actually really hope guy
can cover this in his talk on Monday but
you have enough time to do that so here
I'm just going to show you some of the
idea so some check proto is actually
very important in the whole literature
of IP and PCP and the task is to compute
the summation of a polynomial
multivariate polynomials as defined over
the whole field but only on this boolean
hypercube we want to sum up F from zero
zero zero all the way to 101 and here we
are in the world of polynomial time so
number of variables is log in and then
the size of Earth or the number of
monomials is that least n right it's an
if a piece multi linear and it's
polynomial if it's a larger than that
and computing the sum requires at least
order of n time simply because there are
eleven possibilities of the binary
stream but the word part doesn't want to
compute this on her own so she can
actually deadly take this computation to
the poor side and some check protocol is
particularly for that purpose so the way
it works is the prover is going to send
a universal Nami o on the defy on the
first variable to the verifier in the
first round and this equation is the
formal like definition of how to compute
this universe panel but you don't have
to remember it for the rest of talk but
just uh it's roughly summing up the
boolean hypercube with one less variable
so the sum is of half of the size and
with this universe polynomial the
verifier is going to do some
verification
checking consistency between this H and
this universe phenomena at one x1 which
I'm also going to omit on slide after
that the verifier is going to send a
random challenge to the pool called r1
and using this r1 the pour is going to
send another
Bearpaw Gnomeo defined on x2 given by
this song is again half of the size of
the previous one okay and they just do
it like round by round and eventually in
the last round the pro race is going to
send a universe I know me Oh for the
last variable defined in this way and
the last step of some check the verifier
needs to check the consistency of this
last universe Pournami to the orange no
multivariable know me and the way is by
computing or gain access to this multi
very nominal evaluated at point or one
not two or login so that is the whole
picture of some check proto
and some of the features so as I said if
asked for example is multi-linear that's
the one we are going to use for this
talk there are exactly n monomials or n
coefficients for multi linear phenomena
with logon variables but the proof size
of some check proto is only order of log
n because there are login runs and the
size of each universe polynomials
constant and verification time is also
log n plus this final so-called Oracle
access to this evaluation of the multi
very panel and we are going to explain
how does she get this Oracle access in
the gkr protocol so that is the
soundcheck and it's some of the
occasions in matters
with that as a building block the chica
opera works as for e so it model models
computation as a layered arithmetic
circuit with addition gates and
multiplication gates and input is X at
the bottom and aquas Y so in the first
step we are going to define a multi
variate polynomial or multi linear
polynomial using the input X and we call
it V V P this is exactly the multi
linear extension and the way you can
think of it is as falling right so if X
is X 0 X 1 X 2 and so on so forth
we just want evaluations of this multi
berrineau Meo to match the input that we
want with 0 0 0 to equal to X 0 and then
V 0 0 1 goes to X 1 and so and so forth
so in this way if the polynomial is
multi linear there's a like if the input
defines a unique motive a polynomial
that there's a 1 month making between
the polynomial and the input
similarly we are going to going to
define one polynomial using the values
in each layer of a circuit of course
after evaluation of the hoser in this
way we have a V 0 up to down to VB
after that you can observe that there is
actually a relationship between the two
polynomials defined by two consecutive
layers simply because they're connected
by the circuit by addition and
multiplication for example here is a
multiplication gate it means the
evaluation of v-0 at location 0 equals
to the evaluation of V 1 at 0 0 times V
1 at 0 1 so this is a well-defined
closed form relationship in two
consecutive layers just to warn you the
next one is the most complicated stuff
so this is the key equation in the
jacquard protocol that exactly defines
the intuition I give you basically
defines the relationship between
polynomial of BI and polynomial bi plus
1 so it writes the multi-bear polynomial
VI as a sum of the polynomial VI plus 1
and in addition we have two more
binomials mouths and add exactly mapping
to the circuit as I said because the
relationship is denoted by circuit and
these two polynomials modern ad are
called wiring predicates in the
literature so the input to the thing r3
like binary strings GU and B they are
like labels of the wires in the circuit
and this mod returns 1 if and only if
these three wires or three binary
strings connect to the same application
gate so there is the definition of this
wiring predicate and then if you plug
this into the equation you can verify
that this hose and I'm not going to show
you the derivation and if you thought
about the crack names please ask sharpie
and yo and go about it
okay so with this equation we can
actually did the process of the
soundtrack the G kappa works as falling
in the first round the server send the
claim output y which is not trusted and
this mark being right on the slide this
the verifier is going to define a
multiplayer Panama will be 0 and then
evaluate at a random point R 0 after
that the verifier is going to run a
soundcheck probably the prover on this
equation for layer 0 and as I said at
the end of this sub check the burn is
the Aqua access to an evaluation of the
multivariate polynomial inside the song
so where does she get this auto access
so for the part related to mod and add
she can read evaluate it on her own
because they only depends on the circuit
which is public but for the part about
VI plus 1 just ask the server to send it
to her directly
ok so up to this step like she doesn't
know like we 1 R 1 V 0 0 and y can all
be false I'll be wrong but the guarantee
is that as long as V 1 R 1 is correct
so does V 0 R 0 and output Y so this is
the reduction in the worst case yes but
then if your circuit structure this can
be done in a shorter time sub linear
time and that's exactly why the
verification time can be sub linear for
structure circuits you show it still the
very very time this is linear in circuit
size because
the evaluation yes yes so this is a
reduction of the correctness about
output to an evaluation about values for
one layer below that so following this
idea we can just run one some track for
every layer of the circuit like this and
eventually the verifier can reduce the
claim about output to a claim about
evaluation of the input polynomial at a
location chosen by the verifier so this
is the whole reduction in the GKR
protocol and finally how do we guarantee
that this last evaluation is correct in
the original protocol it requires the
word fire to store the input okely
compute this value really already on her
on her own and checks that they're
equivalent so this completes the whole
reduction of cockneys and guarantees
that the output is correct
so that is the whole description of the
GTR
here this point
and chica pro is actually a very
important protocol for this in Kentucky
theory about efficient interactive proof
or Bangladesh circuits but then the next
question is like what is the exact pure
complexity of the GKR protocol right so
like the chica pro is called doubly
efficient interactive proof but double
efficient just means that the pure time
is polynomial time and the verifier time
is called a linear in the input size
right and like polynomial time is a
sweet word for theoreticians but is
actually not that great if people like
me want to implement it so to answer
this question we have to see what is the
pure complexity of soundtrack protocol
because GTR is basically running one
soundtrack per layer of the circuit so
fortunately we have a quick paper by
Justin Taylor in crypto 13 showing a
very nice technique called dynamic
programming to generate the proof for
some check protocol if F is a multi
linear polynomial actually should be a
multi linear extension but I'm not going
to differentiate them here so the way it
works is as following so first we are
going to initialize an array of this
multi linear polynomial F evaluated on
the whole pudding hypercube right so
each element is just F 0 0 0 goes up to
F 1 on 1 so this is a linear size array
with this array the pourer can generate
the message in the first round by going
through every element in this array so
it computes every element in that song
in constant time so summing them up or
raw it takes linear time to the size of
this array and then there's a way to
update this array by combining two
elements into one with the random
challenge received one where fire and
the size of the array is a cut by half
and then with this new array the prover
can generate the message in the second
round
this one again by going through all the
elements in the array and generate every
element inside this song and again this
that
linear time to the size of the secondary
and then they just do it again and again
to generate all the messages and
eventually this array just shrinks to
one single value okay so that is whole
procedure for the prover to generate the
proof and the complexity is very power
of n plus R 2 plus n over 4 and so forth
which is linear it's optimal for some
tract protocol or multi linear
polynomials and this technique is called
dynamic programming this one is purely
for some tech some check the worth
giving is log n plus this or cracks s to
the which is computing this and the
mouth can be done very efficient so you
can generate kind of what the circuit is
no it's more even the case with another
benefit is proving small no matter what
is the what's the SWAT roster
it's not hard to see that this denim
program technique can be generalized to
like products of multi near polynomials
we just initialize one array for each of
the polynomials separately I update them
separately and my january prove just
multiply the corresponding elements
together and and returned it the proof
okay so this is a class three forward
generalization but unfortunately this
fancy technique cannot be applied to the
gkr protocol because the equation to do
some check on energy our protocol does
not have this nice feature you can see
here the multi-bear panel inside the
psalm so VI plus one is a multi linear
polynomial we have these two our post
multi linear but annoying thing is about
this mod and AD there are also multi
linear but it has a two x log see
variables in it
so if you just apply this dynamic
program technique in a eally the pure
kentukcy
is two to the power of two log C which
equals to quadratic on a circuit side
meaning that if you just want to lay out
this array is already quadratic inside
and time so let along the other things
won't do on top of that for general
polynomials
I think this way of dynamic program
could apply but the time to evaluate to
initialize the array may not be in
linear time so multi linear is one of
the important optimization proposing
just in Taylors
n times D or and time something depends
on the technique very much exploits like
Lagrange interpolation over the boolean
hypercube which really only works for
multi-layer like potentially that degree
two thing in each variable like
everything's I think you can achieve
quasi linear to explain this part city
which I'm going to talk about next so
this complex is not good and to improve
this actually in this paper CMP probe
they improved the complexity of the part
down to quasi linear see Loxy by
observing the sparsity of this
polynomial mode and add remember by the
definition is very impractical it
returns 1 if and only if the three
inputs connect to the same gate so at
most in a circuit you can at most have a
C gates so you have at most C non-zeros
out of the C square possible locations
right so because of this observation if
you think about this big array of C
square size you only have seen on zeroes
so you can index it in a different way
to make it linear but the problem is
that if you do that there's no guarantee
that after update your side of the array
will shrink by half right because
there's no guarantee that two non zeros
go is combined to one right so the size
of the array is always linear he's
always see in all runs so the complexity
is C times log C using this approach and
after that people have spent great
effort trying to optimize this poor time
and the way is to exploit actual
structure inside circuits so in terror
syringe he showed that if the circuit is
regular
for example matrix notation and the
market entry we can make it linear time
and then if the circuit is data parallel
we can bring down the complexity of C
times log C prime where C prime the size
of the small circuit repeating multiple
times and later this is improved to
nearly near C plus C prime log C prime
you know this paper by Wahby at all
anymore for our previous work as a slide
product we show that even if the copies
are different we can still do this C log
C prime is the size of a small circuit
repeated multiple times data parallel
finally in this year in our paper we
managed to come up with a new algorithm
to generate proof in strictly linear
time for arbitrary layered arithmetic
circuits without assuming an instructor
in the circuit so this well just
followed or in your GTR program once on
track for every layer of the circuits so
well in principle you can have
connections between layers but if you
just do some relay gates in practice it
should be fine I don't see any layer
that it I don't see any spark a circuit
that is not layer but in theory it
changing obviously circuit to layer
circuit I think will incur a quadratic
overhead or something yeah so that's why
the claim is only on layer circuit
and this subsumes all the previous like
variants of the GTR protocol so then how
do we do this I guess the key is to look
at this equation like for long enough
time after several years things that are
getting blurred and you realize this
thing can be decomposed in the following
way all the information
yeah that's the circuit think about the
poor had access to this circuit it takes
one like a single step to compute
multiband that's what you know there's
no proposal thing like that just just
think about it just access to the
original circuit the prover has like
everyday written down with the wires
going into that day you can run this
protocol so the way is to decompose this
whole subject into two phases so let's
for simplicity let's focus on the part
with mod because the ayat' part is just
a similar case like this and you can
just do the same trick okay so this sum
can be decomposed into two phases in the
first phase we are going to going to sum
on the first verb or first vector of
variable you okay and then the Sun can
be expressed as the sum of U of this
polynomial H times polynomial VI plus 1
u where H is given by this RB form of
some and turns out both of this final
age and VI plus 1 are multi-linear so if
we can have a way to initialize them on
the boolean hypercube we can actually
apply the dynamic programming technique
in Taylors just inherit paper
and complete this step in linear time so
actually that is the like contribution
you make so we figure out a way to
compute this whole complicated thing
from H 0 0 up to H 1 1 in linear time by
a linear scan of the circuit on this
level and firstly I am NOT able to
present whole algorithm given the
background knowledge here but this is
the idea given a linear scan initialize
H on a boolean hypercube and after that
we just run diamond tenon program
technique on the product of two moti
Liam polynomials and get it the proof in
linear time and this VI plus when u is
the easy part because this the
evaluation in introducing just the value
in the circuit just any sparse point now
yes it can be generalized yeah and then
after the first place the equation
becomes something like this so the
variable U is already bonded or to a
random challenged by the verifier we
call it R of U here so in this equation
we are summing on we only and then this
VI plus 1 ru is merely one value a
single number which is are computed by
the prover in the previous space again
so this is a product of two multi linear
polynomials and we can just apply the
same trick but turns out initializing
this one is not for free we have to go
through the orange like a similar
approach to compute it on 0 0 up to 1 1
by another linear scan of the circuit
from scratch ok and after that we're
just going to apply the time and
programming technique on this one to
finish the second piece so that is the
picture of the whole inner time protocol
if you in some be divided into two
phases in each phase there's a linear
time to initialize a linear time to run
dynamic programming so overall the pure
x linear and also as you mentioned this
can be generalized to anything of this
form
divided into constant number of phases
as long as the polynomial interface in
each phase is sparse it has more than
linear terms and this generalization
actually nicely can be nicely applied to
the orange
equation in the Jakara protocol where
you have identity function identity
polynomial because you call it beta in
the individual construction
or and this part this is the evaluation
for our protocol comparing to all the
variants of existing ones on different
types of circuits and that as you can
see for regular circuits and data
parallel circuits the performance is
comparable to those protocols working
only for those type of circuits and the
circuit is like a random time we have a
big improvement on the running time so
this means that we can just implement
our version and this assumes all
existing ways of only only the Jakara
part another improvements I won't
highlight is after you only have one
version that works for arbitrary
circuits this given gives a very nice
interface that can take arbitrary later
circuits and this is very important if
you ever try to implement ukr protocol
it's really a nightmare to represent
your circuit as the data parallel one
per layer right so now you don't have to
worry about that at least for the
efficient port I'm you can just write it
as a layer that automatic circuit and
this could be compiled from like high
level languages
so we're good with the g'kar building
your time so after this point let's look
at the like the properties of GTR
protocol right the good thing is the
proof size is succinct no matter was
your circuit right so it's D times log C
and the verification is also succinct if
the circuit structure so-called log
space uniform then the verification time
is T times log C plus some work on the
input and the prover time is very fast
Isum taki optimal concretely only
additions and modifications in the
infinitude but it's actually not quite a
pro for our argument system right it
does not allow the prover to have
business ready see that this model is
looked like a little bit different from
yeah when we talk about this in politics
I refer to log spacing problem we talk
about Congress things this is another
you care protocol
yes but we didn't implement the
recursive one for concrete circuits for
concrete ones it just really view it as
data parallel or they can't just the
concrete numbers
yeah and going back it is not allowed to
pour happiness because in the last step
of the gr proko the mirror has compute
this vdr D on her own to finish the
reduction so this requires the verifier
to access all the inputs to compute it
so there's a lot to have witness and
also this problem is not zero knowledge
which I'm going to explain next so to
turn the jacquard broke into an agonist
system in one of our early earlier work
we actually proposed a way using
polynomial commitments okay so the way
works as falling so this is paper in
2017 so we allow the prover to have a
business but the prover is going to
define a polynomial using the witness
which is the multi linear extension of
the part of the business and commit to
it using a polynomial commitment scheme
after that the verifier and pure are
going to run chika our protocol at the
end of this protocol the verifier will
receive a claim about VBR d by the
prover and means that you can commit to
a polynomial and open to an evaluation
point later and it should be saying the
commitment is the constant size their
opening at the precise embarkation times
should be logarithm preserve the
original contacts the FG care
I mean well that claim you just open
this commitment at that particular point
that completes the reduction guarantees
that the output is correct without
sending the videos directly back to the
pool so this is the argument system for
building on top of g'kar okay so that's
great that's the previous work but this
is not zero knowledge to see why is that
the Jakara proof is actually leaking
information
so these universe for nominal stand by
the pool you can think about it as the
weighted sum of the coefficients of this
F where the sum is on the random
challenges chosen by the verifier okay
and then in g'kar this f is defined by
for example two values in a circuit so
you think you can think about these
messages as weighted sums of the values
in your circuit which means it's not
general knowledge think about the case
your circuits are all zero I'm sure that
these proofs will be all 0 or some part
of them will be all 0 so this is leaking
information videos ohms and then how to
turn it into zero knowledge in prior
work into the prior works we actually
take the hammer dummbell transformation
to put everything in the commitments
instead of sending these mess
in plane tax they're going to be embed
them into home market convenience okay
so these are involve our previous work
and another concurrent work by Bobby at
all and then instead of just testing on
a plane tax we are just going to test on
the commitment every time you want to
add or multiply by a constant you do it
homomorphic lee in the commitment every
time you're not a psychology you just
run a signal protocol for equality test
zero-knowledge equality test in that way
you only learn that test comes through
but not any information but this
approach introduces where high overhead
on the verification time right this is
because every addition becomes a
modification our multiplication becomes
exponentiation and I recall it has
become the Sigma protocol for
geologically tests so this is bad in
practice so instead we are taking a
totally different approach and the
project called masking polynomial okay
and the idea was Ernie proposed by
archaea side or in their 2017 paper so
the idea is instead of running some
track on this original multivariate
polynomials we are going to run it we
are going to construct a random
polynomial Delta and to a random linear
combination I run some track on the
housing and impiety linearity of some
track everything still works out and for
security reason you need to commit to
this random masking polynomial and open
it using the polynomial commitment at
the end of some check yeah that's the
that's the idea but in the original
paper they just used a random phenomenon
that is of the same size as the original
polynomial and because of that the
commitments an opening is not very
efficient in practice so in our paper we
show that it supplies to mask with a
very small random polynomials in order
to achieve zero knowledge and the idea
is actually quite simple because some
track is leaking information
but the proof size is only log of C log
log and logarithmic size on the
Thunderer
phenomenal right so you cannot leak like
all the information like all the
coefficients of this point
at most it can leak like the entropy of
log the numbers that means issue suffice
to mask this thing with that many random
coefficients the porch with it stood it
could do it and just the the were fired
was around the minute combination yes
yes so we just follow this idea and
derive everything out and turns out
Delta can be chosen in this nice form
it's just the sum of universe
polynomials which Maps exactly to the
messages of the soundcheck protocol and
because of this whatever you do on top
of this thing committing to it opening
to introduce no overhead because you
mean login exercise okay so this is the
hi-low idea and also thanks partly to
about this idea during our discussion
often works for achieving unity is to
just add something
[Music]
you thought about it but maybe we will
introduce some overhead to the time at
least you know to a success this way is
back the engine is nowhere and so either
they have logarithm overhead also
there's some yes you may save some
constant factor but I'm not very how to
say topics terms you don't have to mask
every coefficient as I said the proof is
only law I'm sending you logs eBay this
on all of the things so you cannot leak
everything right you cannot reconstruct
or enjoy things that's right otherwise
you have a super efficient waited for
transmission so I guess I'm running out
of time and very quickly going through
the last one so as I said there's a nice
way to turn it into an argument system
but the original panel coming we are
using is based on bilinear maps that was
introduced by a mentor at the 2013 which
is a generalization of catalase
polynomial convenient to multivariate
case ok because of this this polynomial
commitment has the trustee setup face
and is also based on knowledge
assumption everything is the same as
snarks so how to remove it we need a
transparent polynomial commencing in
scheme without trust the surface and
this is actually on a wish list of
obvious Christmas thing yeah and here's
a gift for Christmas
ok so the first attempt is how about we
just use the general purpose they are
not proof without fastest error
polynomial commitment or pranaam
evaluation just a special function how
about we just use any general purpose
thing like the girls darker bulletproof
or anything then that satisfied
the requirement right it's a transparent
Panama scheme implemented for example at
the circuit but in those schemes the
verification times linear to the size of
the circuit because there are general
purpose and universe case you have to
read the entire circuits that's why it's
a linear time verification if there is
no pre-processing but that's not the
case for final commitment because panic
and maintenance is a well-structured
computation so the way we do it is by
viewing phenomenal evaluation as an
inner product between the coefficients
and the monomials generated by the
evaluation so here is the universe but
it's just very straightforward to
generalize it to a multivariate case you
take log and inputs as a and then expand
it to a linear size vector all the
monoamine evaluations ok and these
coefficients are our witness known only
to the prover and this whole vector on
the input is public known both to verify
and pool in the first step we are going
to develop inner product based on
general perverse zkp this is a little
bit non blackbox way but you can still
think it as just plug but use and we are
using aurora but as I said the setting
is the verification is running in linear
time actually the one we are using is
runs in quasi linear time just for some
issues but if you do mean to this
verification algorithm
what is this verification doing it
expands ie to the vector of a and then
if you still remember next talk
yesterday is doing some resolving code
encoding using inverse F of T and then
evaluate at the run points using a type
T but these are not important just
explain to a to to F at P so this is the
verification algorithm right but if you
look at it you realize this verification
algorithm takes a small input a
logarithm size and the depth is log in
because FFT and it's very uniform
circuits so how about we just delegate
this thing to the prover and verify it
faster than computing it so we have a
protocol that works for small inputs
low depth circuits and uniform circuits
right it just g'kar
so we just delegate this whole thing
using declare again to the poor side and
the the complexity validated is actually
only logarithm on side of the circuit so
this gives a new polynomial community
scheme without any setup everything here
in black are the same as a row it's
fruit size log and square for time a log
n symmetric here and americo fast and
possibly host calm secure and the only
improvement is on the verification side
its login square this is only for the
polynomial
Pournami commitment and that's exactly
our next slide so putting these together
we get a new transparency KB system
named Virgo the poor time is linear plus
a logon on Venus ice where n is the size
of Venus precise is P log C plus log n
Square where kitchen time is the same if
the circuit is log so it's uniform or
structured in practice okay so I will
end the talk with just some numbers of
the performance so I guess this table is
quite dangerous to showcase we get
complains or around word of it post it
so if you think your system should run
faster just send me your favorite number
and I've update the table okay but from
this ever changing table we can still
conclude something that's exactly the
thing I said at the beginning right
using this thing based on GPA are the
poorer times were fast because it's
strictly linear to a circuit only
addition some applications for the main
body and we still need a key for the
phenomena commitment part but that's
only on the size of the business okay
and there's no way you can optimize
exponentiation to be faster than
multiplication right so and then the
verification succinct for if your
circuit structures in it so that's all
my talk
[Applause]
just in the random foreknowledge like
proof of knowledge yes this is the same
thing as in the paper
yeah and we don't know like we had it's
all about how to be if you can do it
better with better assumptions
[Applause]